it hasn't been any secret recently
about jacksonville and everything going
on in jacksonville i feel like when we
first linked up
jacksonville was bubbling but nationally
it was really just
uh you and osiris oh yeah
uh but now it's like the hotbed of
hip-hop right now yeah i ain't gonna lie
i'm really like
i'm [ __ ] with it like i look i love
to see like my whole city going crazy
like i never hated you know what i'm
saying
so my whole goal was for me to even to
get
get where i'm at and for to create
opportunities for i'm from you know i'm
saying because no like i said it was no
opportunities there nobody
nobody never made it outside of
jacksonville right right right
so for me to get for me to get as big as
i like i am now
it was on the right that i helped you
i'm saying everybody want to come here
but i'll go grab a couple artists from
jacksonville bring them to one man will
record
teach them the game let me teach them
what i know right now i'm saying i'm
going to tell you what i know
and show them like show them the routes
like you feel me it's not that you do
to take it you know what i'm saying so
[ __ ] like that